y
[Música]
se cumple un año de la explosión en el
puerto de beirut en líbano donde más de
200 personas perdieron la vida de al
menos unos 6500 resultaron heridos la
ciudad sigue devastada sumida en una
crisis social y política organizaciones
de derechos humanos que acusan a las
autoridades libanesas de obstruir la
investigación todavía sin concluir
en afganistán el grupo talibán dijo ser
responsable al atentado en kabul contra
el ministro de defensa donde murieron
ocho personas amenazaron con cometer
nuevos atentados contra altos cargos del
gobierno mientras avanzan en el control
por el territorio esto ocurre en medio
de la retirada de las tropas de eeuu
y precisamente en eeuu -el presidente
joe biden y la presidenta de la cámara
de representantes nancy pelosi se suman
a los pedidos de renuncia al gobernador
de nueva york andrew cuomo tras las
conclusiones de la fiscal sobre los
señalamientos de acoso sexual que
determinaron que como acusó a al menos
11 mujeres
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si raúl blanco y
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos en el líbano donde a un año
de la explosión en el puerto de beirut
hay más preguntas que respuestas para
las miles de familias que se quedaron
sin hogar en la capital libanesa y que
sigue sufriendo los daños causados desde
la comunidad internacional hay
preocupación sobre la situación de
vulnerabilidad de estas familias
afectadas al tiempo que se advierte que
miles de toneladas de escombros amenazan
con provocar una crisis de desechos
sólidos si no se resuelve esto lo antes
posible la explosión causó más de 200
muertos y al menos 6.500 personas
heridas además de profundizar la crisis
social y política de ese país los daños
estimados alcanzan los 5 mil millones de
euros cuatro primeros ministros han
pasado en el último año por el poder sin
que ninguno haya logrado formar un
gobierno estable hasta ahora
vamos o precisamente hasta las cercanías
del puerto de beirut donde se encuentra
nuestra corresponsal del bonete hotel
muy buen día primer aniversario de esta
tragedia homenaje a las víctimas un día
de luto nacional le pregunto cómo se ha
levantado y beirut
buenos días más bien buenos muy
calurosos días porque la situación de
hoy hace un calor terrible
beirut pues se ha levantado esta mañana
triste triste y vacía con las calles
desiertas sin tráfico con todos los
comercios establecimientos oficinas del
gobierno restaurants y bancos cerrando
sus puertas al público porque como
decías hoy se ha declarado día de luto
nacional en los hogares de los libaneses
se viven sentimientos encontrados de ira
de indignación pero también de
simplemente asumir la situación porque
realmente en estos momentos el líbano
está con una situación tan compleja con
una terrible crisis económica social y
política que da muy poco margen a la
esperanza esta tarde hay manifestaciones
y se espera que sean muchos los
libaneses que acudan a todas estas
marchas que se van a celebrar de forma
simultánea en diferentes puntos de la
ciudad pero no se sabe cuánta gente va a
poder acudir
o cuánta gente se va a quedar en sus
casas porque la situación como he dicho
es de desolación los libaneses están
desolados y lo único que quieren es que
se haga justicia que se sepa cuándo fue
lass cuando ocurrió y qué ocurrió el 4
de octubre dura y compleja esta
situación que ocurre en beirut él por
supuesto vamos a estar muy pendientes a
esta situación muchísimas gracias uno de
los líderes internacionales que ha sido
protagonista en las ayudas para el
líbano tras la explosión ha sido el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón quien
afirmó esta mañana que su gobierno
ayudará con 100 millones de euros para
la recuperación de beirut y le dio la
apertura a una conferencia internacional
para gestionar dudas
hoy les anuncio que en los 12 meses que
vienen atrás invertirá 100 millones de
euros en nuevos compromisos con apoyo
directo a la población del líbano
quiero aquí anunciar también el envío de
500.000 dosis de vacunas contra el coito
en las próximas semanas durante este mes
de agosto francia también reconstruir a
el puerto que es el pulmón del líbano en
todo el mundo
[Música]
nuevo cargado con 51 toneladas de
material médico ofrecido por francia
llegó a virus la semana pasada y otro
llegará mañana y hoy continuamos con
nuestra entrega de la serie de informes
sobre el año de la explosión el líbano
en un momento en el que el país se ahoga
económica y políticamente como también
lo decía nuestra corresponsal et el
bonete las autoridades se prometieron
que en cinco días se iban a esclarecer
los hechos ha pasado un año y la
investigación sigue sin avanzar por el
bloqueo de las autoridades que se
resisten a levantar la inmunidad a los
políticos procesados el informes de
nuestra corresponsal está el bonito
marie y su familia comparten el dolor
con las otras familias que vinieron a
homenajear la memoria de sahar y de sus
ocho compañeros que murieron en la
explosión del puerto de beirut tenía 27
años ya había conseguido ser una de las
pocas mujeres paramédico en esta unidad
de bomberos la primera y única que
acudió al puerto donde encajar habría
ido de todas maneras al puerto le
apasionaba su trabajo y no reparaba en
el peligro pero sin sus superiores
hubieran estado al tanto del nitrato de
amonio no lo habrían dejado ir
directamente a la muerte fue una
negligencia de los políticos como mariah
mariana perdió a su hermana la explosión
ahora capitanea la lucha de las familias
de las víctimas del puerto y su dolor le
animó a juntar al resto de las familias
y formar una asociación para reclamar el
derecho a una indemnización ya que se
haga una investigación justa hemos
luchado mucho para conseguir un subsidio
familiar para que las familias de las
víctimas puedan recibir la misma
asignación mensual que las familias de
militares fallecidos y ahora estamos
presionando para que los hijos
se han quedado huérfanos de padres
reciban una cuota escolar si pudiera
daría mi vida por la tuya saad eres mi
alma nunca te olvidaré y encontraré la
verdad para ti para mantener la memoria
viva los familiares de las víctimas se
han estado reuniendo cada día 4 de mes
para reclamar justicia y para que la
lucha que han iniciado no sea malo
sólo siento rabia no es suficiente con
que nos paguen una compensación
económica el dinero no nos va a devolver
a nuestros seres queridos queremos saber
qué pasó queremos que los responsables
rindan cuentas
se cumple un año de la tragedia y
todavía no hay respuestas el coraje de
mujeres como amar y animaría animan a
muchos libaneses a unirse a seguir
reclamando justicia en un momento en el
que ni van a afrontar su peor crisis
económica política y social de los
últimos tiempos
vamos hasta afganistán donde los ataques
van en aumento desde el martes dos
detonaciones sacudieron la capital kabul
incluyendo el ataque contra la casa del
ministro de defensa y los talibanes
reconocieron su responsabilidad en este
hecho todo esto ocurre en medio del
aumento de las acciones de los talibanes
que controlan cada vez más el territorio
y luego del inicio de la retirada de las
tropas de eeuu y también de la otan para
entender qué ocurre y cuáles son los
impactos en los civiles tenemos a emilio
viano analista internacional experto en
temas de medio oriente gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros
emilio comencemos por entender que tanto
se está extendiendo el control de los
talibanes en el país y qué implica que
se estén acercando a ciudades como
jerarca bajar y las cargas
pero claramente están expandiendo su
conquista o reconquista abierta de
afganistán en un cierto sentido están
mezclando diferentes tácticas hay
ataques complejos en ciudades y
contrapuestos militares pero tienen
también una ola de asesinatos selectivos
esto es para aterrorizar a los civiles
afganos por ejemplo lo que pasó ahora en
la capital misma cavour contra el
ministro del gobierno es para señalar el
poder que ellos tienen de penetrar la
capital de infligir daño de matar cuando
ellos quieren esto es el mensaje que
quieren enviar a la población para que
no haya más resistencia a su reconquista
del país
ahora acnur ha dicho que cerca de
300.000 personas se han desplazado a
causa de estos enfrentamientos que otros
impactos humanitarios dejan en estos
combates
pero claramente hará una hora por
ejemplo de inmigración de afganistán
hacia hacia los eeuu si pueden obtener
un visado de entrada o a los países
vecinos de derecho
turquía ya está quejándose de la
situación porque ya absorbieron muchos
refugiados del conflicto de siria y
ahora por la posición de los eeuu de
decir los que quieren refugiarse en
estados unidos desde afganistán y en el
primero que dieron a un tercer país y
quedarse ahí hasta cuando nosotros
podamos averiguar la situación y
admitirlos y turquía piensa que ellos
serán uno de los países más afectados
así que era otra ola de inmigración que
podría expandirse también desde turquía
a europa y crear una nueva controversia
sobre la seguridad fronteriza de la
unión europea
hay muchas consecuencias particularmente
también
para rusia que tiene frontera con
afganistán pues ve que están que sí que
están por eso los rusos se están
preparando en obras militares con los
uzbekos en los 'latics' con 1.800
soldados rusos para proteger su frontera
hay repercusiones regionales muy fuertes
a nivel regional pero también
internacional ahora creen ahora para
afganistán con el aumento del control de
los talibanes y la retirada de estas
fuerzas extranjeras como son las tropas
de la otan y también de eeuu y además le
quiero preguntar
emilio si eeuu va a continuar
contribuyendo con la seguridad del país
bueno eso es lo que dicen en lo que
anunció el presidente gane durante su
presentación al parlamento de afganistán
diciendo que todo estaba bien bajo
control en seis meses todos sabían mejor
y anunció también que los eeuu claro han
prometido de continuar a apoyar
el gobierno de afganistán pero esto no
es muy claro porque ya se retiraron las
tropas permanecen tal vez 650 soldados
norteamericanos para proteger más de
todos los diplomáticos y al aeropuerto
internacional pero ya no hay más
verdaderamente una presencia mismo aérea
de los eeuu así que yo pienso que es
casi inevitable que los que los
talibanes van a reconquistar el país
digamos a destruir años de inversión por
parte de eeuu y de la otan en el país
particularmente en los que afectan por
ejemplo las mujeres
las niñas y la paz regional
pues emilio complicaba la situación de
seguridad en afganistán gracias por
darnos este panorama para entender un
poco la compleja situación que tenga un
feliz el resto día nosotros continuamos
con más información porque se
intensifica el escándalo de acoso sexual
que tiene el gobernador del estado nueva
york el demócrata andrew cuomo en el ojo
del huracán tras una investigación
independiente que duró cinco meses la
fiscal general del estado confirmó que
como acoso sexualmente al menos 11
mujeres los los hechos han llevado a que
el presidente de estadounidense joe
biden pidiera su renuncia y también la
líder demócrata de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi damos un
informe que ha preparado marina sardina
mujeres jóvenes fueron acosadas mediante
manoseos besos abrazos no deseados y
comentarios inapropiados por el
gobernador de nueva york andrew cuomo
así lo anunció la fiscal general del
estado destacando que el demócrata
violento sexualmente al menos 11
trabajadores estatales durante los años
2013 y 2020
la investigación independiente concluyó
que el gobernador andrew cuomo acosó
sexualmente a varias mujeres y al
hacerlo violó la ley federal y estatal
s&p clean específicamente la
investigación encontró que el gobernador
andrew cuomo acosó sexualmente a
empleados actuales y anteriores del
estado de nueva york new york state info
y la fiscal también determinó que cuomo
y su equipo trabajaron para tomar
represalias contra una de sus acusadas
por exponer su caso
durante la investigación dirigida por
dos abogados externos se entrevistó a
179 personas
revisando 74 mil materiales entre
documentos correos mensajes y las fotos
desde hacer un peso pesado del partido
demócrata al presidente joe biden
reiteró este martes que como debería
dimitir lo que dije en marzo fue que si
la investigación del fiscal general
concluía que las acusaciones eran
correctas recomendaría que andrew como
renunciar a eso es lo que estoy haciendo
hoy no he leído el informe no conozco
los detalles del mismo todo lo que sé es
el resultado final sin embargo desde que
estalló el escándalo hace cinco meses
como de 63 años siempre ha negado las
acusaciones este martes volvió a
mostrarse desafiante
you know that we for me
primero quiero que sepan directamente de
mí que nunca toque a nadie de manera
inapropiada
hoy se insinuaciones sexuales
inapropiadas la normativa del estado de
nueva york dice que el acoso sexual
incluye conductas no deseadas de
naturaleza sexual que crean un ambiente
de trabajo ofensivo 2019 como fue
defensor de una ley estatal histórica
que facilitó a las víctimas de acoso
sexual probar su caso